Thank you very much to the DAVA team for inviting me to give this talk.
I'm going to talk about strategies to mitigate ocular toxicity from Belomav.
So Belomav is back, as we've heard, but can we manage the ocular toxicities?
I would argue that, as we've talked about in the era of bispecifics and CAR-T, Belomav
still retains some relevance as an effective BCMA-targeted therapy for patients who may
not be appropriate for a T-cell redirecting therapy.
We've also seen from DREAM7 and DREAM8 that efficacy is still quite significant, with
DREAM7 demonstrating a significant PFS and OS benefit.
However, the key challenge is, can we manage the ocular toxicity that we see with this
drug?
Ocular toxicity with Belomav is generally reversible and can be managed with dose holds
and interval extension, dosing interval extension.
But it's important to note that it is very common.
In the DREAM7 study, according to the package insert, 92% of patients had ocular toxicity.
So before we go forward, I just want to show what these ocular toxicities actually look
like on exam.
So shown here on the left is in vivo confocal microscopy, with the top row being the
pre-treatment exam.
And then you can see, with the development of...
With the development of these toxicities, you can visualize these superficial punctant
keratopathy, these microcysts that develop in the cornea on the bottom row.
And then shown on the right is the slit lamp exam findings.
To better define what's actually going on in the cornea, we participated in a multicenter
effort to collect some corneal samples.
By either impression cytology or superficial keratectomy in addition to tear fluid collection.
And this study showed that there were corneal epithelial changes characterized by eosinophilic
inclusions and apoptosis in the cornea.
In the ADC, the antibody drug conjugate was detected in the tear fluid in most of these
patients.
And this pattern suggested that the drug enters the cornea via the cornea.
And this is a very common pattern in the ADC.